[Musique]
une question qui intéresse quasiment
toutes les villes de martinique
peut-être d'autres de façon plus accrue
comme le lamantin ducos bientôt ça tu
sois encore le vauclin des villes qui
ont vu l'implantation de centres
commerciaux à leur périphérie cette
question donc quelles dynamiques locales
pour revitaliser les centre villes
bonjour olivier razemon beaujouan
nourrissent gueuleton journaliste
écrivain conférencier spécialiste des
questions de mobilité de transport
d'urbanisme et de mode de vie première
question 13,7 de façon globale comment
se portent les centres villes alors ça
dépend où
mais effectivement on a une situation
qui est qui est également qu'on retrouve
parfaitement de l'hexagone c'est à dire
qu'on a des dents les villes moyennes
une situation difficile à la fois parce
que les commerces sont fermés parce que
les beaucoup d'eux des habitants ne se
vivent plus la donne on a beaucoup de
logements vides
on connaît ça évidemment à fort de
france mais aussi dans beaucoup de
villes de la martinique mais mais aussi
dans l'hexagone c'est très très général
et puis on a des équipements qui souvent
sont installés en de l'extérieur de la
ville les hôpitaux les pôles emploi les
les caisses primaires d'assurance
maladie etc
on l'a des transports publics ils sont
pas forcément très utilisé ou pas
forcément optimaux on a des sentiments
d'insécurité assez fort dans les villes
également dans certains endroits alors
je parle à la fois de martigues que si
l'hexagone
également incertain beaucoup de villes
du sud de la france les gens ont un
sentiment d'insécurité
donc voilà il ya tous ces essais ces
choses là dans le train en fait on est
en train de payer le prix de 50 ans
d'étalement urbain où on a finalement
pris les attributs des villes pour les
mettre à l'extérieur et bien finalement
au bout d'un moment on se rend compte
que dans les villes n'ont pas plus grand
chose parce qu'il ya encore le
patrimoine mais met à autre il ya moins
de choses qu'avant alors une politique
appliquée pendant 50 ans en 2018 2019
on va considérer qu'il ya une prise de
conscience qu'il faut peut-être arrêter
de faire comme ça oui je sais ce que je
gagnais plus de deux ans maintenant je
suis partout en france j'ai vu à chaque
fois que je mets quelque part je vois
des gens qui prennent conscience tout le
monde pas forcément mais il ya partout
des gens qui se disent d'abord
initialement les les élus en particulier
mais aussi les forces vives de la ville
les citadins les associations
des sentiments que ça leur arrive et
seulement eux moi j'ai entendu ça à
niort j'entends de sa vierzon s'est
passé comme ça chez nous et en fait ils
ont pris deux comptes pris conscience
que c'était général ça c'est une
première chose et puis ensuite ils se
disent maui attendait en est en train
d'étaler la ville toujours plus loin
enfin on a déjà des tonnes et des tonnes
de zone zone commerciale bien sûr et
puis on a des tas de voilà les rocades
des parkings partout autour de la ville
de la moindre ville de la moindre ville
de 5000 habitants que c'est de
concentrer des commerces des services
sociaux zones bien précises
oui alors la question qui se pose
aujourd'hui c'est pas tellement de
savoir ce qu'on va ce qu'on va faire de
la bd
comment dire de la périphérie existantes
elle est là on va pas la détruire
d'ailleurs parfois le seul esprit tout
seul parce que il ya des thèmes tels
concurrence que les que les zones
commerciales périclite également j'en ai
vu beaucoup j'ai vu des friches
commerciales en périphérie mais par
contre la question de savoir c est ce qu
on continue comme ça
ou est ce qu'à un moment on arrête un
avec les conséquences que ça pose parce
que la ville a posé la question
la ville nommée rue il faut arrêter non
mais la ville la ville ses pages une
source aujourd'hui vous demandez ça
dépend pis ça dépend où bat le
saint-etienne qui vous est cher le maire
et d'entrain dacquois de construire une
nouvelle nouvelle zone où j'ai posé la
question jeudi mais attendez vous avez
un centre ville vous avez vous avez eu
la république il ya moins de commerce
vous avez place jean jaurès et et il me
dit bah oui mais non mais je sais c'est
quand même mieux on va concurrencer lyon
mais ça fait des décennies que essayer
de concurrencer lyon rayon comprend
saint-etienne et on continue de c'est la
fuite en avant permanente
alors puisque vous êtes rendus dans
certaines communes de martinique le
chaos bouclé le cas de sainte luce où il
existe des projets de centres
commerciaux vous diriez croit aux
autorités politiques de ces cônes de ces
deux communes alors bon je vais pas
arriver le gars qui débarque de paris
pour raconter ce qu'il faut faire danser
je suis pas sûr que ce soit une bonne
idée mais sauf que le concept du jeu
sont les mêmes sauf que le voilà je
constate que la même chose partout et on
a effectivement une session très très
différente à
à sainte luce nikkei rose le maire dit
on veut pas de l'un veut pas du projet
de zone commerciale carrefour parce
qu'il dit ça va tuer le boer
on a une bourgade animée avec des
restaurants des commerces qui fonctionne
bien si on rajoute une zone là c'est
n'importe quoi et pourquoi comme ça
parce qu'on a promoteurs privés
oui qui veut installer son centre
commercial sont les élus n'y sont pas
d'accord les commerçants ne sont pas
d'accord ça seul le débat se déplace ou
sur le plan juridique alors juridiques
qui sont en train de le faire puisque le
permis de construire a été il ya un
sursis à statuer mais bon voilà le
groupe hayotte pour pas le nommer est
tout à fait déterminé à vouloir faire
son sens son centre commercial
manifestement par contre là le débat
public et ça je trouve ça intéressant
c'est ça pèse
ah oui ça pèse parce qu'après ça va
c'est d'ailleurs ce qu'il a dit à une
caisse monrose était déjà dans les
élections de 2014
mais ça sera dans les élections 2020 il
ya un hiver y avoir des discussions sur
ces sujets moi j'ai vu des villes
tournus en saône et loire en
l'occurrence qui a basculé sur un projet
de ce genre là et la population
massivement à dire on veut pas de ce
truc là et donc la population dit si la
population dit sable ça devient plus
compliqué ça devient un sujet politique
c'était un sujet économique jusqu'à
présent c'était rationnel dans ce genre
de débat par exemple ce groupe que vous
avez cité le groupe hayotte qui à
quelques kilomètres un autre centre
commercial déjà à à ducos est ce qu'on
peut lui faire entendre
cette argumentation que vous risquez de
tuer de l'emploi par exemple dans le
centre-ville
leur argument c'est qu'ils vont créer
l'emploi sauf que personne ne fait le
lien avec ce qui s'est passé avant quand
on regarde ce qui s'est passé depuis dix
ans est-ce que telle zone créée il ya
dix ans à créer l'emploi ou pas en fait
on s'aperçoit quand on regarde tout ils
ont créé un peu mais ils ont détruit
aussi beaucoup donc effectivement il
faut avoir des chiffres pour sa démo
pour objectiver le débat à dire autant
dire regardez ce qui s'est passé dix ans
avant ça c'est un premier sommet venons
ils ont alors ils ont leur logique
c'était pour vous jusqu'à présent c'est
la grande distribution
avec un raisonnement qui était purement
économique était et est souvent les
mères aussi c'était du dv cocon ni
développement économique enfin en fait
une zone là une d'ailleurs zone
d'activités aussi au fait on ajouta les
autres activités qui parfois sont vides
bon état et c'était du dev écossais ne
savait pas vocation à rentrer dans le
débat public ce qui rentre dans le débat
public c'était la sécurité c'était les
transports c'était cette animation de la
ville mais c'est tout et là on a de plus
en plus dans le débat public dans de pas
partout hein
de plus en plus un débat qui vient sur
ok est ce qu'on a vraiment besoin de
cette zone supplémentaire et ça je
trouve ça salutaire olivier heureusement
la population s'y retrouve quand même
dans ses centres commerciaux on a beau
dire on n'en veut pas on ne veut pas une
fois que parce que le groupe
le promoteur a eu du temps a eu de
l'argent et de la patience a eu des
avocats et tout ce qu'il faut comme
service juridique pour pouvoir
finalement exercer son passage en force
la population s'y rend tranquillement le
samedi repoussant ça pour ça il ya dix
ans on a eu un service est ouvert
jusqu'à 22h bien sûr il ya des gens qui
font ça et quand et quant à ica est
arrivé orléans tout le monde s'est
précipité pendant quinze jours c'est la
fête c'est vrai mais c'est la grande
différence entre l'intérêt particulier
l'intérêt général est ce qu'on fait est
ce qu'on continue billets toujours je
trouve toujours des jambes pour vous
dire c'est plus près de chez moi sera
plus simple etc
sauf que qu'est ce qu'on fait est ce
qu'on est là quelles sont les
conséquences
on parle des conséquences on a compris
les conséquences en matière de commerce
mais les conséquences en matière de
vitalité ça veut dire qu'il ya plus
personne en ville ça veut dire qu'on a
un patrimoine historique ancien avec des
bâtiments superbe avec comme je les ai
vus ici à fort-de-france des des
ateliers d'artistes des bâtiments et cdd
endroit qui valent la peine qui font
l'identité du pays désolé c'est ça aussi
c'est l'identité du pays et là y'a plus
personne parce que non mais dans les
centres commerciaux dans les grandes
enseignes avec les sûrement mais puis
dans les centres-villes à l'abandon en
on retrouve les en discordance wee cc on
est on est dans un sujet de reims 8%
pour le couvent purement politique est
ce que on tient à nos villes où est ce
que finalement l'objectif c'est
simplement de faciliter la vie du
consommateur
je crois que c'est vraiment le débat de
société du moment et on voit en train de
voir en vain l'hexagone avec avec six
soirs de gilet jaune que manifestement
c'est de cette idée de purement faire la
société pour le consommateur en disant
qu'il est roi partout tout le temps et
que quels que soient les autres
conséquences et quel que soit le nombre
de kilomètres qui font ensuite dans les
bouchons et en consommant leur essence
c'est ça n'a plus de sens et ils le
disent dernière ils sont très très
rapidement est ce que l'ensemble des
élus ont pleinement conscience de cette
problématique
mais ça l'est pour lesquels moi j'en ai
rencontré lamartine qui ont paru
pleinement conscience d'autres moins
c'est normal c'est normal il ya des gens
qui ont pris conscience qui est
franchement il ya non plaisir qui m'a
café le m'a fait l'honneur de m'inviter
assemblée je crois qu'il a pris
conscience du sujet manifestement on a
beaucoup discuté il ya deux élus qui
l'ont et c'est normal on arrive en inde
il ya un problème où il n'avait pas
forcément envie ce problème là et
maintenant il faut il vous faire
autrement car c'est compliqué de faire
autrement c'est très compliqué j'en ai
parlé beaucoup avec eric piolle le maire
de grenoble
il est il du bain il faut arriver à ne
plus faire ce qu'on faisait avant c'est
ça le plus difficile c'est la pente la
plus douce il faut arriver à sortir de
la pente la plus douce merci olivier
heureusement ont d'abord été avec nous
rappelle quand même que vous avez écrit
un ouvrage comment la france a tué ces
villes donc une question que se posent
ils se posent chaque fois qu'il ya un
meurtre à qui profite le crime mais bon
on va vous laisser on va laisser les
martiniquais les auditeurs parcourir
votre lit faut avoir peut-être la
réponse merci la france merci beaucoup
merci morice
[Musique]